foreign
let's go to Angela in Colorado Springs
what's up Angela
hi John how are you good how are you
I am well today
that's an excellent uh qualifier today
yeah I'm all right yeah
I'll take my wins there you go it's how
can I help what's up
oh okay so we are about two and a half
months into a few Transitions and
traumas my husband just recently
returned from his fourth deployment
and we have three children 16 12 and 3.
and just shortly after he returned from
his deployment my oldest daughter
her one of her closest friends and one
of our neighbors and 16 year old boy
committed suicide oh man
and so we are like I said today is a
good day but we go through cycles and
Transitions and I just want to be sure
that we're bonding as a family and that
my kids have what they need and my
marriage has what it's needs and that
I'm taking care of myself as well
throughout all of these transitions into
traumas right now yeah no kidding
um how has re-entry been for you and
your husband
was great the first couple of weeks and
then that's Fantasyland automatic events
yeah yes it's the first few weeks of
return are always uncomfortable and
awesome because you can just make out
it's all better and then all of a sudden
after that I'm right right and then
after that it's like oh gosh we live
together now
yeah
yeah and I struggle with transitions
anyways and so it's now we're coming
back around but there are moments where
it's
it's a struggle yeah
and you're being super super vague what
does that mean
struggle like he's struggling with PTSD
he's not sleeping
um he just keeps shaving and leaving
little hairs all over the sink and
you're about to stab him with his own
toothbrush like what do you like
he had an affair while he was over there
you had enough like what are like give
me a range of what we're dealing with
I think it's mostly me he there's no
PTSD he does really well with his
self-care and taking care of his mental
health there was nothing traumatic that
he experienced all over there it really
was just the fact of us being away from
each other creating our own routines
um being in in that transition after
they leave then I'm in my own thing I'm
in my own space I'm taking care of the
kids the way that I do it and then they
come back and there was some time that
he was home on leave and it was good and
then now he's going back to work a
couple weeks ago so now it's a whole new
set of
um circumstances and routines and it's
it just seems like there's no
consistency in schedule right now
especially in the midst of the holidays
as well absolutely so when things feel
this chaotic
the most important thing you can give
yourself there's two important things
number one
your body is Desperately Seeking for
homeostasis for stability
okay that's not going to exist for a
season
it's very similar to like it's winter
it's going to be cold this week my body
will be searching for warmth it will not
find it outside with me standing there
I'm underwear it just won't
I'm gonna have to either go inside where
there's a heater on or I'm gonna have to
change my I'm going to put on a lot of
clothes a lot of layers and jackets
but I'm gonna have to do something
different because it's just simply not
going to be warm outside I gotta own
that that's reality so instead of your
body every day being frustrated and
beating your head up against the wall
and starting to get angry start to get
resentful that well now the schedule is
Goofy again and I was going back to work
and now there's this and now we got to
get on the in a car and drive to
instead of beating yourself up that way
this leads me to number two you can
grasp for what you can control which is
maybe day by day maybe week by week
and if you use the magic sentence what
does your picture of today look like
what is your picture of this week look
like and you all commit to doing that
every day tell your husband I need this
right now because I'm still toggling you
weren't here and then you were back and
you left again now you're back and by
the way
um then you now you go back to work now
we're gonna be like
a gift to me is how do you imagine how
do you see today going and I'll pitch in
on what I've seen and we're gonna we're
gonna be very clear together
and so we're gonna slowly practice
bringing stability back into our lives
it's not just going to magically be here
and by the way as soon as you get it
it's it's going to take about 18 months
to be like all right now we're here and
then your 16 year old's gonna go to
college and the whole thing starts over
again
right
yeah this is the rest of our lives as
frustrating as that sounds and so most
people spend most of their time at war
with change
I have chosen to love it
now I have to lie to myself sometimes
because I don't always love it but cool
doing something different today What's
it gonna be
and it's just it's a skill it's
something you practice over and over
again but it starts minute by minute day
by day would your husband sit down with
you for 10 minutes in the morning just
to say hey what's your picture of today
look like
yes he he is good at those
things okay I would
maybe for the first time in a long time
because you've been survival you've been
a single mom
um I would start to
write down on a piece of paper here's
what I need in this new season
and it's still strange to me when we
write my wife and I do this exercise in
this new season here's what I need and
it's like I just need you here I think
I've talked about the show sometimes my
wife will say for the next few months I
just need Chit Chat
I don't really know what that means but
I sit at the counter and we just talk
about whatever
and for her that makes her whole
parasympathetic nervous system kick in
you see what I'm saying like being able
to say here's what I need right now I
just need you to sit by me and hold my
hand I need you just to watch a show
with me I need you to
can we just tell funny jokes we just
read from an old book for me I don't
know what you need but let's have that
conversation as it relates to your
daughter
um
a couple of things you can do number one
I would have her
um write him a letter okay
um but how much she misses him how much
she's how mad she is at him
um what he's going to miss this upcoming
year
but encourage her to write that letter
um and maybe there will be a second or
third letter over time but this is one
of those formative moments she'll
remember this moment for the rest of her
life she's not going to remember the
things you said unless you say something
really stupid
um which no pressure right
um
the but she will remember that mom
showed up and mom was warm
and mom kept showing up and mom kept
showing up and mom kept showing up Mom
believed me Mom listened to me mom held
my hand mom took me for ice cream
mom listened when when I read that
letter and here's another
um important thing you could do
you can write a letter to him and you
can read it to your daughter and let her
know this freaked you out and this broke
your heart
and that way she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore because right now she feels
isolated alone if she knows Mom's
hurting too then she feels connected to
somebody
how's that sound
it sounds good why are you crying and a
little and it just it and the mama bear
comes out you know
I don't know what she's experiencing I
can't get in her head and that's why
writing down is so important because it
takes what's inside and puts it outside
yeah
and some kids really need to talk and
verbally process this
I remember when my friend Greg died when
I was 14 I sat in my room and I held my
dog and I wept hard all by myself
I remember that
I remember when a boy a little bit older
than me died by Suicide and I went in my
room and I just wept alone all by myself
that's what I needed
and then there's another season when
there was a tragic bus wreck when a
bunch of young people were hurt or
killed and I had to go I've got on a
plane and flew home because I just
needed to see my dad I need to see my
mom
so it's been different moments and
different seasons of my life different
tragedies different things going on my
brain couldn't compute a Bus full of
kids get in a wreck
they couldn't compute it it overloaded
and I needed to go sit down and see
somebody uh see some like talk to my
talk to somebody who was safe and so
it's just going to depend let your
daughter guide that but it's the let's
just keep showing up
let's start going to breakfast together
once a week
I gotta go get gas will you come with me
no you're coming with me you have to
come
you can choose either Sonic or Dairy
Queen but you gotta come
and by the way if you choose Dairy Queen
we're all going to have indigestion
that's very true but you see what I'm
saying like I'm going to show up it's
less about having all the right things
to say
and more about I just kept showing up
and I just kept showing up and I just
kept showing up
and I'm gonna encourage her to write to
talk to sing if that's what she does to
play guitar yeah
music is her life yeah maybe ask her to
write him a song
okay and then play it for you
okay creativity helps a lot but it's
that Mama Bear don't steal grief from
her don't steal her uncomfortable
feelings from her she has to be
uncomfortable a friend of hers died
she's going to ask that question what
could I have done what should I have
done
and that's when some wise counsel can be
he wasn't okay
and there was things going on in his
heart and in his mind in his home that
you will never know about it's
heartbreaking
can I read you the letter I wrote to him
and that's how we're going to slowly get
into that conversation
so one other thing before I let you go
it's really easy when we have a ton of
stuff going on afford all to blur
together on us
we got holidays and we got husband
coming back home and now we've got this
suicide in our neighborhood and plus
I've got this Christmas party from my
little one
it feels like it's all coming down and
it's not there's three or four really
heavy things right now
so let's be really intentional about
pulling those apart because sometimes we
can really be having a tough month
financially and we had a fight and
there's a Christmas party and it just
feels like the world's collapsing on us
and it's not we have three hard
situations
I'm gonna start driving for Uber I'm
effective immediately
you and I let's sit down on Saturday
let's go to breakfast together and let's
talk through this because you're my one
and only let's figure this thing out and
let's play Paper Rock Scissors fruit's
got to go to this Christmas party right
let's pull these things apart control
what we can control and not let the
smoke of what it feels like everything's
on fire it's not there's just three
small fires burning or three big fires
burning but they're all different fires
it takes a lot of patience and it takes
a lot of courage to wade into those
individual fires and for most of us we
can't see it when the Smoke's so clear
it's so thick and that's when we have to
get friends and other people in our
Lives who walk with us and go whoa whoa
It's Just Three Fires burning there's
just four fires burning
let's attack each one of these things
and get them knocked out
the smoke will clear on its own
your husband's lucky to have you Angela
so those those little ones
I'm sorry about your loss